it's the thing that's crazy to me about
Twitter is how like it delivers that
content to you let me talk about this
before like old internet used to have to
go like seek that [ __ ] out yeah
it like you till you know you had to
like go to Rotten calm hmm I felt like
it was like you knew was in your
personality yeah like I enjoy gore yeah
you know I mean yeah Twitter you you
have like such a pass
oh yes people post it you can just play
oh I accidentally saw a dick going in
another dick like that's some [ __ ] I
should have never seen explain that
explain it I don't know if I can it's
this chick and the thumbnail is like
it's like the end of a dildo and what
you can't even tell that's what it is I
mean I could because it like she's got
thick did you god yeah yeah it's like
she's got the top half of the end also
in her mouth yeah the bay just looks
like it's like this weird plastic thing
in her mouth and her mouths open super
wide yeah well the shape of her mouth
and how there was only one color yeah
like just signal to me there's a dildo
you know it's kind of like if you were
to be eating your own kneecap or your
fist that's what her face looks like
she's got this thing that she's shoving
in there and then you see you play it
and she starts pulling out the dildo and
it's just like it it's legitimately like
18 to 24 inches long 24 dude that [ __ ]
was 2 feet look you know like neo in the
matrix when he's pulling that tooth out
of his [ __ ] throat that's what it
looked like she's like
and a person yeah on the video is like
or yeah I think they're like watching
the video aren't they isn't isn't like
the cell I sent us the one with it was
actually her okay okay yeah
and so she finishes like some English
girl she's like I feel fine
just a soft with [ __ ] eyes of just
it's just like just crying for three
hours yeah you feel fine now wait till
you're in the hospital with [ __ ]
internal bleeding
that's like organ damage straight up
dude you can't nothing is meant to go
[ __ ] three feet into your stomach
it's like curling up in the bottom of
her stomach from the stomach acid like
oh yeah she definitely like if if there
was anything she was worried might be
sitting around in her esophagus it's not
there anymore
yeah only [ __ ] there just pulls it out
like snaking a bathtub pull there like
corn and it's the worst like like
weirdest feeling seeing that like it
starts and you're like oh she's like
deep throwing at oh yeah oh oh woah oh
god what the other half comes out and in
the word man she's got the head half of
the base of it also in her mouth yeah
she could have did the balls too she
could have did the balls to like
something she does a David Blaine [ __ ]
where she just spits it back out no she
just eats it my name's Caroline okay
Caroline where are you from from
Manchester by moved to LA like last year
okay what's your talent just pulls out
big like no no you know that big like
that ropey gummy worm you know that
giant gummy worm no they make giant
gummy worm
yeah yeah it's like an end of a firehose
yeah well I'm gonna swallow this whole
thing yeah
immediately sir no she doesn't even say
it she just he just holds it up and she
like she like kisses the head like she's
a big boy that's it a little bit enough
you starts like warming it up you doing
the pepper grinder she kisses it like
licks it like she's about to give it a
head right his car TVs about it or
[ __ ] MLB's about to hit the [ __ ] X
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Caroline and I'm just gonna Simon's like
sorry just looks at her blankly
dismantle the gold button just send the
right to the final like Auto advances
you like to the end okay but it usually
like give some big speech he just skips
it he just hits the [ __ ] but they sit
there in silence for five seconds like
just completely it's like all the
confetti comes
thank you every round after that like
the fan voting yeah your favorite
Caroline everyone else
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
these are custom